what am I looking at what am I looking
at guys can I read the title sure
um
[Music]
so the mom uh the title of the mom comes
home way early at 11AM after she said at
5am doctor said doctor says dad doesn't
have long
so that's the mom walking out he's
filming her the beginning of the video
is just him filming nothing then this
when the mom walks out this is of course
Dayton hypernova who used to be Jack
Sparrow in high school
so he's just filming her walking away
that's right that's right you caught her
you've got a red-handed bringing a
sandwich to your dying dad and film your
grieving mother
bring a peanut butter and honey sandwich
to her [__] dad to your dad who's
dying now
get ready for what his real issue is
oh my God my dad's house or whatever his
status is with things only thing I know
is that I was asleep in bed when she
started I had to take my door shut and
she started like
I don't know if she was banging on the
doors or like knocks out really loud or
trying to open it she was like kind of
like
jittering the handle really loudly and I
was slowly waking up
yeah she's probably panicking and in
shock because doctor said that your her
husband doesn't have much longer to live
not even having enough time to respond
to her because I was uh coming out of a
drunken stupor you [__] prick yep
I'll
sound at my bedroom door and she kind of
without even opening the door she calls
out from the other side saying that the
doctors don't know how much longer dad
has
or she said more specifically the
doctors say they don't think he has very
long I think that's how she said it
which is a scary thing to say very
vaguely
there's not much vagueness to it he has
cancer he doesn't have that much longer
I mean what do you and I think what she
was saying is maybe you should get in
the car and go see him right [__]
piece of garbage exactly not making a
little hate videos in your little room
alone
I mean that's a scary thing I assume
that she means Royce pretend pretend I'm
I'm like your brother or something say
dad's dying I'd say the doctors say dad
does not very long the doctors say Dad
isn't ever alone Jesus Christ okay let
me uh let me find somebody uh to watch
the plays I'll let my boss know
um give me like an hour and a half I'll
be there see
it's that simple that's all you say
that's all you do Jesus okay I'll get
there as soon as I can well let me tell
you you want me to tell you what he's
posting on Facebook while this is
happening because I have that here you
go I just I'll read it
from a cade a paradoxia on Facebook
this is probably going to sound vain but
it's one of those things as a person
reflects upon as they turn a year older
as things about their life and Hometown
peers confuses them of nearly one I'm
reading it the way he's writing and I'm
not you know of nearly 1 000 Facebook
friends I hardly ever see this with
other people but happens to me most of
the time in Dayton no one shows any
support to my new main pick when it's
uploaded he's just found out his father
wait this is today yeah he's complaining
that nobody's giving him enough likes on
his new uh Facebook profile picture
what is
wrong with him and then and then and
then he posted a picture
of it and he circled it where it says
not one like since uploading this 48
hours ago
what's wrong with him
piece of [__]
I you know what it is man do you know
what it is to make frozen angry like
like really angry not kfabe like do you
know what it is to hear Frozen say in
that tone you piece of [__] you want to
read this one
Tavern for my birthday the past hour
longer I've been hearing my parents
shouting downstairs about my dad's chemo
pain stressing stressing me out hey can
you knock it off with the chemo talk
you're stressing me out it's really sad
and then he circles that not one like
since 48 Hours here
okay just I I gotta say I got the
highlight of my day was just here at
Frozen go
oh [__] someone breaks someone breaks
into his house someone breaks into your
house like stabs you to death and he
said can you stop bleeding it's
stressing me out my dad's cancer is so
intense it's causing a foul statue over
the upstairs hallway clear into any room
with an open door and he's downstairs
the entire time uh I'm complaining by
then uh I'm complaining by venting about
it but I know it's awful for him just to
have to hold the breath when I every
time I leave the room okay that was like
a hint of self but no but he's still
complaining about the smell being a
problem to him
he just can't well how come nobody liked
this Facebook picture guys what's wrong
with it nobody likes this guy I don't
understand
seems so likable
I don't know because you never say
anything else she walked right out the
door before I could even get out of bed
because I was barely awake when she said
that it was like okay but here again you
come in my room and go dad probably
doesn't have much longer I'm away yeah
of course no matter what yeah you're
awake now you're like [__] all right
I'll I'll stop for coffee on the way to
the hospital but uh we'll figure it out
I'll figure it out all right I'll be
there that's all you do you garbage
human
it's like the Baseline things that make
us human you know yeah even family you
don't like yeah it's like oh [__] really
okay all right I'll get there five in
the morning
it was like so I wake up startled by the
time I'm out of the like even able to do
anything
to like talk to her she's already gone
to the hospital so anyway it's like can
I recognize him
she hasn't texted me about this stuff I
don't know I mean it's hard to talk to
her
she doesn't speak to me
yeah you make yourself so welcoming who
would want to he speaks for other kids I
get Social Services totally normal to
speak to them but it's very difficult
for her to speak to the one that's out
of the closet and she has a very strict
religious view against that Megan about
himself dad just find out his stats
isn't that much longer making about
religious views and trans stuff so
anyway I guess she came home to get him
get to add some food to take to the
hospital I don't know what to think I'm
in you know so much you know
so much I'm under so much stress from
the thought of what she was saying he's
under a lot of stress merch I hate him
so much I out of all the like we went
from covering the guy I love the most on
this show yeah to covering the person I
hate the most on this show yeah he is
just such garbage man and this is coming
for me I'm a garbage person but my God
even your Baseline garbage friends do
like are not this bad all right man I
got you I'll have you back on that like
Jesus dude earlier
[Music]
and she's so you know
cool and calm and buy the book right now
and she comes home acting so not nervous
that I don't know what to think she's
putting on a brave face man what are you
a brave face of Lies anything but she's
really Sage [__] thanks for reading
the AI script I made at least one
including the ROTC Universe have good
ones thanks seriously like who bangs on
your bedroom door and says or you know
really loudly says you know doctors
don't know how much longer he has and
then like she says it's so coldly that
I'm like oh my God
it's awful [__] really I just you
know consideration and come home in a
total how dare how does she be sad that
he doesn't have much time left seems
relatively calm I guess right now
the way she was this morning right now
she seems calmer but then again she's on
the phone with my younger brother are
you like on the phone with him he's out
you know in another state you know
talking to her so it's obviously bad
enough to be talking on the phone with
him about whatever the condition the
stat status of your dad is like whatever
his condition is right now or whatever
all that [__] it's crazy it's worrying
me like hell right now and I don't know
what to do or what to feel well you know
what I would do just I'm [__] baby
baby I'm [__] sick maybe I'm a
[__] sicko but like I would do what
every family does in this situation
here's the thing [__] when when
somebody's in the hospital whether it's
a car accident it's cancer whatever it
is a stroke right the whole family comes
to the hospital I'm gonna let you in on
a secret [__] nobody sitting in that
Lobby knows what to do yeah nobody knows
what to do you just hang out you comfort
your family and you pray and if you're
the one that's if you're one of the
people that has a car you occasionally
go hey I'll go grab something you want
to get food or something yeah I'll bring
it back and that's what you do nobody
knows what to do when somebody's on life
support or somebody's sick and I was
like you just go you go and you sit
there and that's like Dude nobody
encapsulated that better than The
Sopranos because they had like everyone
there when uh Tony got shot or whatever
and it was like everyone was at the
hospital but they showed how the adults
conducted themselves they showed the
kids being bored and annoyed you know
what I mean like that's that's what you
do you have like kids fidgeting all
night and people sit and they wait
because Grandpa's dying
functional Guardian messed up family I
don't know I'm just sad they all seem to
look we all have our [__] problems we
all have [__] flawed families but it
seems to me like with you removed right
like it seems like they have a pretty
okay Dynamic I'm pretty sure your sister
and your brother-in-law probably up at
the hospital right now one or the other
while the other one's watching the kids
good point and I'm sure you [__] all
that your little brother that came from
out of town he's out he's here because
your dad's dying and I'm sure he's up at
the hospital your mom's making peanut
butter sandwiches for him everyone's
doing something except you so yeah they
might be dysfunctional everyone's family
nobody's perfect but they're there and
they we've watched so many videos where
they enjoy each other's company and
they're just having a little goddamn
barbecue and eating hot dogs and the
kids are running around and it's like
they all seem pretty happy dude I hate
them
can I get another one Frozen
I can't I I'm very upset yeah right now
yeah it's rough right